So, let me ask you.
You probably go through great pains to prevent Mr. Pickles and Gabriella from dying, if I'm not mistaken.
Well...
Yes.
Right.
Is this what you normally clean your house with?
It's whatever on sale, it's usually blue or yellow?
That would be correct.
Yes.
Well, here's a problem with that.
It's extremely poisonous...
...and it's really dangerous...
...and I can show you statistics and experiments...
...that prove that my product doesn't only clean better than those, but it's safer.
But if I've shown you one thing is that, that is really boring.
So, instead, I'll just do this.
Experiment.
I'm impressed.
I am.
ScieoClean is the best cleaning product that's ever been invented.
It's completely natural.
It's completely safe...
...and it cleans better that any product on the market.
If any of my competitors are making the same claim,...
...all I say is come on TV and drink your product.
But I don't think you will.